the observable universe has a diameter
of about 92 billion light years within
it are planets nebulas asteroids the
list goes on but what would happen if we
got rid of the single planet
specifically our largest planet Jupiter
how important is this gas giant to our
solar system how would it affect life on
Earth and how would this change Earth's
development this is what F and here's
what would happen if Jupiter never
existed if Jupiter was no longer in our
solar system having one less planet to
aspire to travel to would be the last
thing we'd have to worry about this gas
giant ranges from 600 to 1,000 million
kilometers away from Earth but despite
it being so far away from us
we'd experience direct implications
right here on earth why is this well to
say that we'd noticed Jupiter's absence
here on earth is a bit of an
understatement this is due to earth not
being around at least not in the current
state as we know it today sure it would
still be some sort of planet but it's
very unlikely that there would be any
complex life forms no fish animals and
certainly no humans earth has been hit
by tons of asteroids and other space
rocks according to some experts they may
have brought water and other essential
substances down to earth but although
some asteroids can be good there's
plenty of bad ones some would be big
enough to wipe out entire civilizations
just like what happened to the dinosaurs
65 million years ago this is where
Jupiter's role comes in although it has
slipped up a couple of times throughout
the history of our solar system Jupiter
has been protecting us as millions of
asteroids have been heading towards
Earth Jupiter's gravitational pull has
grabbed the asteroids
this puts them in Jupiter's orbit and
unable to reach earth without our giant
protector earth would be hit by a lot
more asteroids and it's unlikely that
another planet would step in to fill
Jupiter's place considering that the gas
giant is the only planet big enough to
attract all these asteroids this means
earth would get hit by thousands more
asteroids than it ever has before some
would be small and could maybe help
earth bringing us new elements but it's
possible earth would get hit by a couple
of big ones enough to destroy anything
that would be evolving on the planet and
may be enough to destroy earth itself so
we know we probably wouldn't be here if
Jupiter had never existed but what if it
suddenly disappeared today our solar
system would have developed in the exact
same way but Jupiter suddenly blinked
out of existence for more on how our
solar system as a whole would shift and
get all out of sorts you can check out
our episode what if earth was the only
planet in our solar system but if only
Jupiter disappeared it might be a good
thing despite being our protector
occasionally Jupiter messes up and might
miss a couple of things
Jupiter threw a comet towards us 350
years ago luckily it missed us but it
wouldn't have been anywhere near Earth
in the first place if it wasn't for
Jupiter hey guys Peter here I just
wanted to take a moment out of doing the
voice over to come on and talk to you
about our sponsor for today's episode
curiosity stream curiosity stream is a
video streaming service that has
thousands of award-winning documentaries
shows on dinosaurs shows on the earth
shows on outer space right now I'm binge
watching one called a travelers guide to
the planets and I'm actually just
finishing the one or I've finished it
actually I shouldn't lie to you finished
it it's called Jupiter and it's apropos
of this video that we're doing right
here because this thing's on Jupiter -
one thing I've learned and I'm not sure
it's coming up in the video but
Jupiter's moon Io has volcanic fountains
fountains of volcanic lava spewing out
and rolling river
lakes of lava the place is pretty cool
anyways curiosity stream is offering
what if fans a chance to get the service
for 30 days for free and after that if
you want to stay on $2.99 a month for
the subscription or $19.99 for the whole
year which is actually a better deal if
you do the math trust me you can sign up
right now at curiosity Stream comm slash
what if and be sure to use the promo
code what if during signup use that
promo code and it actually helps us out
here at what if anyways I'm gonna stop
talking I'm gonna get back to this
Jupiter video despite Jupiter
occasionally throwing some space rocks
our way it has largely helped us
throughout history so I'm gonna say it's
probably best to let Jupiter stay in our
galaxy agreed how about instead of
getting rid of Jupiter why don't we fall
into it and see what mysteries it holds
well that sounds like a story for
another what-if